so what are your education plans then
well actually my my focus in education
is informed by my own background and my
own experience if I look back in my own
life yeah I've done well for myself now
thankfully but I had a lot of challenges
but they were overcome largely by the
folks in education both by my family and
the schools that I went to and it was
transformative for me so I think schools
your colleges universities all taken
together are the biggest engine of
social justice in our country today and
it's something I want us to take as a
country you know much much more
seriously so what I'd like to do that
mean there's a lot but what I'd like to
do is to make sure we are properly
investing in our schools and our further
education colleges I want to see a
multi-year multi-billion pound boost in
spending and investment in schools and
really change the life chances of so
many young people sounds expensive
you're gonna raise taxes to pay for it
no I won't what I'll do and I've thought
about this very carefully I spent years
in the you're working in fine house I
spent time in the Treasury
I was also business secretary
responsible further education and I've
taken a cabinet experience what I would
do is I would slow down the rate of debt
reduction government debt reduction at a
small portion of GDP all right well no
debts will still be coming down into a
portion of GDP I would just slow down
the rate of reduction I think it's
important that we head in the right
direction but by slowing that down it
could free between 15 to 25 billion
pounds a year of spending which will all
go into education there's other
priorities like local government time
but there's enough there to reinvest so
has the Chancellor push things too far
then in your view with austerity no I
think that this Chancellor the
Chancellor before him if you look back
at 2010 and what was inherited there
were the right policies for that time
but I want to be looking ahead I think
we need to reset our relationship in so
many areas education is one of them if I
can say so from when I was growing up
you know I remember education for me my
this is what my parents really pushed
you I I just get home from school and my
mom will say have you done your homework
yet and just going through the door you
I'll be marched to the library at
weekends my mom will be looking over my
shoulder and these are but you can read
she couldn't she couldn't read she was
at a school in Pakistan and your girls
at that time didn't go to school but
she's actually the cleverest woman I
know but she couldn't read but she'd
still be looking so have you read that
word did you read that chapter properly
and you know that's how I sport up and
I'm also well aware that you're many
people don't have strong families like I
was lucky to have so I also at the same
time want to focus on families and how
we can make them stronger because
there's too much family breakdown in our
country as well and I want to see how we
can strengthen families too I mean you
were saying about the importance of
education but your own education perhaps
wasn't well it was very contrasting to
other of your colleagues and at school
you were advised to become a TV
repairman though doesn't sound like it
was perfect the comprehensive thing you
went into it wasn't at that time the
school wasn't very good and not only
that I was I was told that I couldn't
study maths at a level so I had to you
know get my dad to pay for it I had to I
was told that I could only study to
a-levels when I knew that I was told
that you have to have three to go to
university so I had to change schools
and go to a local college but these are
struggles I don't want other people to
have so you know my vision for this
country what I want to see for this
country is that people that have had you
all have your similar challenges like
those I've had I want to level the
playing field I want them to have much
more quality of opportunity I want them
to know that if they have a go they can
succeed now I want to move on to
practice it because this is clearly
going to be top of anyone's entry
whoever becomes the next prime minister
so what briefly is your plan my plan is
to first of all accept the realities I
totally except what you've said this is
going to be the number one thing for any
new prime minister and what I mean by
accepting the reality is that you've got
this Parliament with this speaker we
know the Parliament is divided and so
you have to deal with that as you find
it so I will then turn to the only thing
the only thing that's got through this
Parliament so far which is this wood
wall agreement with changes to the
backstop you know a a - a time limit or
some kind of proper exit mechanism and I
will take my debate to Ireland because I
think the key is Ireland and I would
work with them and I would also do
something different because I realize
you can't get the same thing - to work
if you don't change something so what I
would do
is I would offer to pay for the new
alternative arrangements on the border
it would be in the hundreds of millions
I propose to do that because
economically it's right and morally I
just want to stop that that the problem
with the IRA situation isn't money it's
peace I mean people aren't worried about
the thought of a border or any kind of
infrastructure in Ireland because it's
going to cost too much they're worried
that people are going to get killed over
it I mean it's it's the wrong solution
that's it well actually i'm acutely
aware of the situation and the borders
as Home Secretary being responsible for
security that occurred I'm acutely aware
that and that is something that everyone
every single one of us has to take very
seriously and that is why I've done my
homework on this you're what is needed
is everyone agrees you need some even
the Irish governments agrees in
principle it agrees that even if the
backstop happened it cannot persist
indefinitely that it will have to be
replaced with alternative arrangements
and that means the border has no
infrastructure on it it remains an open
border as it is today now the key is how
can that be done I've got border force
in my department they've been doing work
on this for months it can be done it can
be done with existing technology it can
even be done in a couple of years
what you need is both sides to work
together you know you're talking about
facing up to the realities here you've
said before you want to see honest and
credible proposals but I just put you
that many would think these are not
credible proposals just to look for
example Karen wheeler quit this week as
boss of the UK born of delivery group
she said there's no technology solution
which which would mean you could not
have a hard border there's no magic
solution if there was trust me you would
have found it I mean many would say what
relying on a unicorn well I'm not this
isn't either of course you don't need a
magic solution for this the solution
exists they we've done the homework on
this you know border force doesn't know
if the solution exists why isn't Therese
maple because of that because I think
the key is I think most people to
understand you need cooperation on both
sides of the border to make it happen
you need both sides to be able to sit
down have some working group and make
this happen if I can lead you that when
she couldn't because I will change the
dynamic and I will do that
by offering the money to pay for the
border and and let me just say it is
really important is that it is justify
that we do that because economically if
that unlocks a deal we'll have a mean
the economic boom in this country if we
get a deal and that will pay for that
and also because we are both committed
to peace and the Good Friday Agreement
it's morally right that we do this okay
very quickly can you guarantee that if
your Prime Minister will leave the EU by
the 31st of October like what I can
guarantee is that the policy of any
government that I lead will be to leave
on October the 31st we will do
everything in our power to leave on
October 31st and that does mean to me of
course I want to deal I will do
everything I can to have a deal but if I
have to choose between no deal and no
brexit I would pick No Deal okay now I
want to talk to you about a story that's
been dominating the newspapers the last
couple of days yes before we can get and
Michael Gove admitting that he has done
cocaine in the past something he says
that he regrets firstly if you done
drugs and do you think is acceptable for
someone who is running to be prime
minister to have done drugs given the
fact that they're illegal it's not for
me to pass judgment on your fellow
candidates you're any Tory MP if they
can get the nominations they can run as
a candidate and they've got to make
their case
you know I will make mine they can make
their case at the same time your Home
Secretary well as Home Secretary I'm
very happy to speak about drugs I'm not
what I'm not wanting to speak where any
individual I don't think that's a
appropriate but yeah when it comes to
drugs and especially you people have
been talking recent about middle-class
drug use I've talked about it a number
of times that it is you people do need
to know it doesn't matter what your
middle class not anyone that takes Class
A drugs you're they need to think about
the supply chain that comes from
Colombia let's say to Chelsea and the
number of lives that are destroyed along
the way so people who take drugs have a
responsibility today to think if anyone
who takes drugs should be thinking about
how they are not just hurting themselves
but how they are destroying so many
countless lives on the way and you know
there are people that you know they they
have their organic food they boast about
buying Fairtrade they talk about climate
change and at the same time you come
Friday or Saturday night they're all in
Class A drugs and they should be
thinking about the impact they're having
specially on children and with the rise
in county gangs and the the horrific
abuse I've seen as Home Secretary
of young children that are being
trafficked into this trade so people
anywhere you should be thinking about
the impact they're having on others
absolutely okay now one of your biggest
decisions as Home Secretary was to strip
the Islamic state bride she'll move
begum of her British citizenship and a
fairly controversial decision at the
time and of course shortly after her
baby died a three week old baby what did
you feel when you learned that that baby
had died well I can't talk about any
particular case the weather is to do
with deprivation of citizenship and
things they're not appropriate
especially if there might be legal
action going on but I'm happy to talk
about that sort of more generally you
can talk about your feelings they caught
it maybe I can't get into okay it's not
appropriate it's a there's a there's a
legal case and it wouldn't be
appropriate as Home Secretary to get
into the details of a particular action
but you know you've asked me a very it's
a very important question nevertheless
and which is about protecting our
country from terrorists it has Home
Secretary you're the difference between
Isis I would say this job and I've run
three other departments is that it
really bears on you every single second
of every day that you have to take on
the responsibility of protecting this
country and that does involve taking
some tough decisions to do what you can
to protect British citizens and if that
means that the only way that you can
keep out a terrorist from this country
that could otherwise come back and harm
others and indeed kill others and the
only way to do that is to remove their
citizenship under the full advice that
you've received from intelligence
services from legal advisors from home
most officials then that is what you do
and I would not hesitate to do that all
over again we up see if it would lead to
the protection of British citizens why
are you upset when you learn that the
baby it dies i I said I can't talk about
a case but if you're of Court but let me
just say that there are innocent
children that have been either taken by
their parents to Syria to fight for
terrorist groups or they're being born
there and and of course they are
innocent victims in this conflict and
the people that are responsible for
their deaths are their parents
that took them there in the first place
and
birth them there and now the Muslim
Council of Britain Britain's largest
Muslim organization has said that there
should be an investigation into
Islamophobia in the Conservative Party I
just want to ask if you think that the
Conservative Party is ready for a leader
who comes from a Muslim background to be
a leader I I think the the country not
just a caserta party I think the the
country is ready for leaders including
in politics and we've seen in other
walks of life from all sorts of
backgrounds and in the cassette of party
or ray I'm proud and I've been
privileged to be I think I think I'm so
fact I know I am the the first person of
there's not white that's the holding a
great office estate I'm very proud about
that but I think it's a it's great that
that's happened in the Conservative
Party I think the country is ready I
actually think when I compare Britain to
so many other countries and I travel as
ministers and I see ministers from other
countries there's no doubt in my mind we
are the most successful multiracial
democracy in the world have you
experienced any racism in Parliament or
in your journeys opponent not in
Parliament not not since I've been in
politics you as it growing as a child
absolutely you know sadly you know many
times and and you know there's the kind
of things that you never forget but you
know I do what stick in your mind then
oh well being called [ __ ] you know being
attacked by NF skinheads you know when I
was younger and things and and punching
back a few times and something I don't
want anyone to go through but those are
the kind of things you never forget and
it actually I think it charges you up to
want to do more about social justice and
fighting hate crime than before but if I
can also say that sometimes I do think
of myself as a bit of an outsider it's
not just because of race or or you know
that it could be my working-class
background at schools that I went to I
do I do think that and and I think
sometimes there's a strong case to have
an outsider to actually become the
leader because it can shake things up
yesterday I was very lucky to get the
endorsement of Ruth Davidson you know a
real election winner young but someone
have got nothing please now and the
minute they of you well let's wait and
see let's wait and see these things can
change very quickly but
Ruth Davidson I think why our mission
says someone whose it was a bit of an
outsider when she was picked to lead the
Scottish Conservative Party and look
what happened and how it was transformed
and sometimes I think when your party is
Israel is fighting to be heard one of
the best ways to get your message out
there is to do something different
pick a bit of an outsider and and and
then you get people to listen to you
okay again just briefly if you want
people to listen to you
Sky News is gonna be holding a live
head-to-head debates between the final
two candidates and the race if you're
one of them we commit here to taking
part absolutely I think there's great
that you're doing it thank you very much
okay thank you very much Home Secretary
thank you